youtube ein ort voller toller video
creator intellektuellen konnten und
musiktalenten die seinesgleichen suchen
auf dieser plattform können sich
künstler aus leben ihre werke
veröffentlichten bewertungen bekommen
kommentare bekommen channel können von
leuten abonniert werden die user die
ihren content hochladen können
werbeanzeigen daraufhin und daran geld
verdienen und dann gibt es noch luca bei
dem circa jedes video als nicht werbe
freundlich eingestuft wird dort youtube
an der stelle haben vor einiger zeit ein
video hochgeladen das habe ich im land
+18 die heftigen failed dort habe ich
quasi auf ein video reagiert in dem die
leute sich wehgetan haben das haupt
video auf dass sich dort reagiert habe
übrigens die brille habe ich ja auch
weil ich mal wieder sherlock holmes wenn
die brille letztlich einer seite zu
kapital von anderer seite aus dem staub
zu machen also immer zu machen weil die
nicht ansatzweise irgendwie ein bisschen
versuche klug zu sein
bei dem video stadt reagiert habe hat es
nicht um ein video gehandelt das nicht
ab 18 freigegeben wurde also quasi ein
ganz normales video und hab ich mir
gedacht okay wir sind brutal aber wenn
der pop video nicht mehr beachtet aber
nicht sein dann habe ich sogar einige
stellen das video verliert weil ich
wirklich auf nummer sicher gehen wollte
bin dann einige tage später mein video
manager gegangen habe gesehen mit
altersbeschränkung ich meine dass
urheberrechtlich geschützte inhalte
enthält war klar welcher video reagiert
aber mit altersbeschränkung ich meine es
wirklich vollkommen ok youtube wenn
jetzt bekommen wie beispielsweise hier
enthält urheberrechtlich geschützte
inhalte oder hier oben mit den
urheberrechtlich geschützten inhalten
oder hier oben
ihr seht ständig bekommen tatsächlich
sehr häufig als legale vollkommen in
ordnung ich meine bei urheberrechten
komplett nach noten bei der
altersbeschränkung konnte ich nach
dementsprechend dann halt nicht dann war
aber wieder so zwei drei monate ruhe das
verhältnis zwischen mir und youtube hat
sich wieder vielleicht noch mal hier nur
eine video konnten vernünftig
hochgeladen werden die wurden vernünftig
verarbeitet vernünftig dargestellt ich
habe relativ selten wird bekommen die
platz 18 und sollte wenn ich jetzt die
tage in meinen mail-account gegangen und
er auf einmal so eine mail von youtube
und die schreiben dort nehmen
wir haben ein video geprüft und dabei
festgestellt dass die inhalte wie video
details nicht werbe freundlich sind
deshalb kann der video nicht
monetarisiert werden ich dachte dann
halt erstmal so ok um welches video
handelt es sich denn da habe ich da
vielleicht irgendwelche menschen
abgeknallt irgendwer die rassistischen
äußerungen getätigt oder nackter haut
gezeigt wie es handelte sich dabei
wirklich um das video ich spiele google
ich mache also ein video über ein spiel
was sich auf google bezieht sehr gut
gemacht youtube und feucht das ganze
allerdings viermal schritt für schritt
analysieren was denn da der genaue grund
sein könnte warum das video nicht mehr
befreundet ruby jetzt erstmal meinen
guten kollegen markt dann mag ich ihn
was er davon hält berufe max kann man
hier für geheilt hat eine ganz kurze
frage weißt du warum eine meiner letzten
videoaufnahmen ich wieder rubel nicht
werbe freundlich war könnte das der
grund sein könnte es wirklich daran
liegen dass youtube mich hasst youtube
die größte video plattform weltweit eine
der größten social media network welt
bei eine plattform auf der sie künstlich
so viel wie material hochgeladen wird
diese plattform hat nicht gönnte das
beweggrund sein das video hat nicht
werden freundlich nach stellen zu lassen
youtube behält sich das recht vor die
endgültige entscheidung im hinblick auf
die video monetarisierung zu treffen
mehr einfluss darüber wann william video
zur monetarisierung eignet findet in
unserer hilfe bevor ich jetzt hier
wirklich mal vom schlimmsten ausgehen
schaut erst mal die hilfe an und schauen
wirklich ob die darin vielleicht den
grund finden denn die youtube verwendet
zu einer weltweiten community bei indem
diese richtigen den beachteten dazu
beitragen dass youtube für alle nutzer
ein angenehmer und sicherer ort bleiben
wir jetzt also zu den community
richtlinien und ich würde sagen wir
schauen jetzt einfach mal ob ich davon
eine eventuell nicht beachtet habe als
erfüllte inhalte hier erfährst du wie
wir mit inhalten umgehen die zu hass
oder gewalt aufrufen habe ich nie
gemacht in dem video dafür mit meinem
namen schädlich oder gefährliche inhalte
her fährt mit inhalten die ungeeignet
oder gefährliche handlungen schildern
was
ich hatte zeit computerspiel gespielt
dafür stehe ich mit meinem namen
belästigungen cybermobbing so gehen wir
mit belästigung und cybermobbing umwelt
schon habe ich in dem video mich selbst
beleidigt dafür stehe ich mit meinem
namen bohrungen hier erfährst du
videoinhalte meldet die
gewaltandrohungen enthalten welcher
youtuber droht gewalt in dem video an
aufwärts rica für steffen kleinem namen
werden ihre funde metadaten und betrug
hier wendete richtlinien und anderen
aktivitäten mit denen nutzer in die irre
geführt werden oder getäuscht werden
sollten was der titel ist ich spiele
google und spiele ein spiel was ich auf
google suchbegriffe bezieht hier stehe
ich mit meinem namen gewalttätig oder
grausame inhalte junge spielzeit
computerspiel dafür stehe ich mit meinem
namen laden auch nicht weil ich an allen
sachen die rechte habe nackt und
pornografischen inhalte auch nicht
identität igstadt was
das passiert höchstens in euren scheiß
kommentaren bei dieser umstellung
youtube ich da meine kommentare ein
thema so fiesen kommentare von in
welchen anderen usern die auch kontraste
also nicht welche komischen links
verbreiten gefährdung von kindern
weitere richtigen und rechtlichen
richtlinien nein ich habe alles davon
beachtet und ich habe solche arten von
solchen video schon so häufig
hochgeladen wenn ich auch einfach mal
ich halte übrigens die ganze zeit
einfach so ein akku in der hand ich weiß
gar nicht warum wenn ich einfach mal
meinen videomanager rein gehe und
highline gebe das ist nämlich das spiel
fertig gespielt haben dann sieht man bum
ich habe davon schon sieben videos
hochgeladen und nur dass hier wurde
nicht monetarisiert freunde versteht
mich nicht falsch es geht nicht darum
dass ich jetzt an dem video was werde
ich wie viel geld nicht verdient habe es
geht einfach nur darum dass ich auf der
suche nach dem grund bin ich meine es
gerechtfertigt ist okay aber ist es
nicht vor wir uns allerdings weiter auf
die suche nach dem grund begeben meine
damen und herren habe ich noch eine ganz
gute frage an euch kennt ihr alle
sicherlich widgets binner
diese teile sich zu drehen und gegen
stress sind und so ich weiß dass der
hype mittlerweile so halb vorbei an die
tat nicht mehr durfte videobild retten
und so weiter ich habe jetzt leider die
möglichkeit bekommen mit einem netzwerk
findet wieder raus zu bringen den mann
hinten auf sein handy ploppen kann also
quasi wie von probst rocket man hinten
drauf hat und ein handy anbietet und
travian beim handy mittels penalty noch
abnehmen kann und dort seine neue sache
die wir und kriege überlebt hatten
ich hab ihn allerdings besagt ja also
eigentlich hätte ich bock drauf das ist
halt moment mai die logo drauf aber ich
weiß nicht ob meine community das will
und zwar dürfen entscheiden ob ich die
kinder produzieren werde ich hier oben
eine umfrage eingeblendet warum
funktioniert da können wir drauf endlich
egal ob ihr gerade am
laptop oder am tablet oder am iphone
oder handy oder fertig sei und da könnt
ihr abstimmen ob ihr wollt natürlich
solche fit rausbringen oder auch wieder
nicht wollt und wenn ich danach folgt
die lippen einstellen und sich halt
nicht aber wir wollen zu fahren dann
kommt ein paar tagen der shop online
könnt ihr euch die teile bestellen und
die werden eh nicht so teuer sein also
das wird jetzt kein unglaubliches
geldgeschäft es geht nicht mehr darum
das ist eigentlich eine gute idee war
und mich gefragt und ich habe gedacht
bevor ich leide und ich wollte fragen
übermalt worden
an der umfrage teil und sagt ihr eure
meinung aber jetzt zurück zu den
wesentlichen sachen meine damen und
herren ich frage mich immer noch wie du
das video hier nicht monetarisiert wurde
am markt meinte die band hatte könnte
würde daten betreibern formular mail an
youtube ich befinde mich noch immer ob
der youtube richtlinien webseite nach
unten scrollen sehen wir job über und
werbetreibende entwickler hilfe
willkommen in der youtube hilfe hier
sehen wir jetzt ganz schön ihre hilfe
hilfe videos bekannte probleme hilfreich
kompetent fachlich versiert ob
beitragende an diskussionen teilnehmen
willkommen im offiziellen youtube hilfe
bochum suche nach antworten stelle eine
frage und lerne mehr mitglieder thema
und dann würde ich sagen komm crafter
hallo mein video von vor einigen tagen
wurde nicht monetarisiert da ich in dem
video nicht großartig andere publizierte
kund getan habe als in bisherigen teilen
leiden der video serie der fall war tut
sich nun die frage auf ob youtube mich
hasst den leuten da auch noch mal meine
kompetenzen sich in dieser sachverhalt
darzustellen und wirklich auch zu zeigen
wie er diese ganze situation ist nochmal
darunter könnte das vielleicht der grund
sein und dann einfach ganz ganz viele
zeichen hinnehmen sodass wir sehen dass
man das wirklich tatsächlich selber
ernst meint dann hängen wir noch von
bild dran hier unten und machen einfach
mal foto von meinem computer auswählen
ich habe jetzt einfach mal ein foto
angehängt
gefunden habe natürlich mit einem
stromberg t shirt glaube ich irgendwie
habe ich gemacht habe und einen vogel
gezeigt habe und ich würde sagen wir
einmal auf pausen geben die arbeit für
den beitrag ein muss ich auch nochmal
machen habe ich einfach ganz große hilfe
damit die leute sehen das wirklich ernst
gemeint ich bin da noch posten und an
dem gestorben
kann es sein dass youtube mich wirklich
hat ich möchte eines klarstellen ich
nutze youtube auf dem airport mein leid
über die monetarisierung mein
betriebssystem ist windows mein browser
ist vom posten
jetzt als mein beitrag leute ich packe
ich den link zu diesem beitrag hier
einfach mal unten in die video
beschreibung ihr könnt darauf klicken
und ihr könnt dann dort argumentieren
was ihr denkt warum
youtube mich hart bz warum ein video an
monetarisiert wurde heute mal wirklich
konzern zu sein er mit gegen den video
halt darum dass ich quasi link eine
anzeige hatte mit einem begriff von
jubel und die oft dieser begriff
irgendwie monatliche berufen wird und es
scheint ein anderes bild man muss sagen
auch dass häufiger oder weniger häufig
gegoogelt wird als bereits vorhandene
bild und an einer stelle kam halt und
diese terrororganisation islamischer
staat grund dafür nennt samt mehr
gepackt und denn das wirklich der grund
ist youtube
man sieht dann ist es einfach nur dumm
ich habe weder irgendwelche dummen
aussagen darüber getroffen noch habe ich
irgendwelche rassistischen äußerungen
getroffen oder irgendwann irgendwie
gewalt verherrlicht oder so ich habe
lediglich gesagt dass dieses entweder
heutiger oder weniger heutige google
wird als ein vorhandener begriff also
was macht das für einen sinn ich habe
übrigens auch schon beschwerde
eingereicht
aber die antwort erhalten das ist das
wurde noch mal von uns geprüft das ist
wirklich nicht werbe freundlich ich
verstehe nicht wie youtube auf die idee
kommt wie die so was machen kann aber
ich meine gleich hassen sie mich
wirklich wie gesagt ihr findet den
linken aber schreiben könnt ihr einfach
mal mit mir da so rege darüber
diskutieren ich weiß noch gar nicht was
mich da jetzt hier bringt überhaupt ich
habe zwei aufrufe ja wahrscheinlich von
mir vorhin und weil ich gerade
aktualisiert habe cool locker an der
stelle möchten wir noch mal anmerken
meine damen und herren das gibt mir sehr
sehr leid ich mit meinem video vor
einigen tagen so wer hier getan habe im
herzen dass ich wirklich gedacht hat
auch scheint die das überhaupt sagen
youtube oder bekommen jetzt einen streik
vielleicht sogar video gefallen hat will
ich mich selber nike freunde findet oben
die infrage eingeblendet wo ich mit
sagen können ob die fritz in einem job
haben wollt und ja schreib doch mal eine
kommentare was ihr denkt was der was der
grund dafür dass youtube
mit
wegen